AMIR SHEVAT: So hi everybody.
Thank you for coming.
I hope you've enjoyed
Google I/O up until now.
My name is Amir Shevat.
I used to run Campus Tel
Aviv, if you heard about that,
and now I run our global
startup outreach out
of developer relations.
We have a distinguished
list of panelists
and I'll let them
introduce themselves.
Yep.
Let's do that.
FADI BISHARA: Great.
Thanks, Amir.
So my name is Fadi Bishara.
I'm the founder of Black Box.
We are an accelerator based
here in Silicon Valley focusing
exclusively on helping startups
from outside of Silicon Valley.
So we act a little bit
more like an accelerator
off other accelerators.
We help some of
these companies come
in here and access resources
and launch into this market.
EDEN SOCHAT: Hi.
Eden Sochat.
I guess I built stuff.
So I build GeekCon I
spoke about before.
Biggest geeks conference,
makers conference in Israel.
After that, The Junction which
is now the number one startup
accelerator in Israel.
After that face.com
that is now Facebook.
Before that, Eternity
that is a company that
is not very interesting
but is growing really fast.
And now part of a VC in Israel
called Aleph, a $150 million
fund out of Israel.
ROY GLASBERG: So
I'm Roy from Google
running developer relations
programs for Europe
and running Campus Tel Aviv.
AARON HARRIS: I'm Aaron Harris.
I'm a partner at Y Combinator
down in Mountain View.
AMIR SHEVAT: So the topic
of the conversation,
unless you have other
interesting topics,
is the connection between--
the difference between startups
in the Silicon Valley and
startups outside of the Silicon
Valley.
So the first question I have is,
we hear a lot about the Silicon
Valley, we hear about
the Silicon [INAUDIBLE],
we hear about the
Silicon roundabout.
I'd like to know, what is,
in your way of thinking,
what is the difference
between startups here versus
startups outside, and what are
the different challenges they
have?
FADI BISHARA: I start again?
AMIR SHEVAT: Great.
FADI BISHARA: OK.
So startups in Silicon
Valley, they're
playing in a familiar
environment, familiar ground,
experienced ecosystem.
A lot of the participants
have come from companies
that they've been through
some of the fast growth stage
so they have a lot more
experience in stepping
out and starting again and
launching their companies.
So that's one of the
most obvious distinction.
The ecosystem that we have here
doesn't exist anywhere else
and in the capacity
it does here.
I've been travelling the
passed three years more than 40
countries and I'm meeting
with entrepreneurs all around
the world, and the common
things that I see different,
that is they lack the expertise
of experienced entrepreneurs
who are mentors and experts who
built companies themselves that
they typically would be
very effective in helping
the founders in that journey.
So the startups there, they
tend to be a little bit more,
in my opinion, more
hungrier, attachment
to who they're working with.
One of the things that I've
noticed in Silicon Valley that
is-- well, of course,
the willingness
to fail in Silicon
Valley or the permission
to fail that we have here
doesn't exist anywhere else.
In Europe you're pretty
screwed if you launch a company
and raise money and
then the company fails.
You probably can't get
job in some countries.
So the issue that
I think here is
kind of like went a little too
far is we've taken this failure
concept I think to an extreme.
Where a lot of
entrepreneurs here
are just swinging
the bat just looking
for very high, fast
growth, and if something
doesn't work there isn't
the kind of sinking
their teeth, the bulldozer
thing that I think if I meet
good entrepreneurs, passionate
entrepreneurs outside
of Silicon Valley, they tend to
be a little bit more attached
and more persistent in figuring
something out and doing
something that works well.
So the issue with failure is
definitely much more difficult
for them, there's
not enough ecosystem,
they're trying with Greenfield--
not much to learn from.
Startups outside of
the US, they tend
to-- the founder-- they tend
to drink a lot more beer which
is, I think, another advantage.
And, yeah, that's probably
what I can think of.
EDEN SOCHAT: So I guess Israel
is fairly similar in many ways
to the lack of
issue with failure.
So that's something that
differentiates Israel
from most of the
world and makes it
fairly similar to
Silicon Valley.
So Wix, the founders' recent
IPO-- $1.2 billion IPO--
failed in their three
previous endeavors.
Another thing to keep
in mind is Israel
is a very small country--
so 8 million people--
of which 270,000 are part
of the high tech industry.
So that's a pretty small number.
But they own 16% of the GDP.
So it's a highly
centralized-- that's
one of the fastest money
suppliers to that market.
And as such, you still have a
constant scarcity of resources.
So in many ways,
Israel, the disadvantage
is distribution, by far.
And we'll talk about
distribution later I think.
Because it is away from
that central market.
But the other disadvantage
which becomes the advantage
is scarcity.
There is relatively less
capital and so, for example,
pre-money valuations in
Israel is much lower.
Money is not as available
which makes companies much more
efficient.
That's the upside of
starting up and being
able to fail many times,
but that's also the downside
because when we want to
grow, having someone funnel
$50 million checks
is not as common.
So that's the biggest
differentiator.
Yes, there's absolute
willingness to fail,
distribution is not as
easy, money is more scarce
making companies--
starting a company easier
because people are used
to, but it's harder
to scale the
company's afterwards.
ROY GLASBERG: Totally
agree with what you guy
said so I can add maybe
two interesting points
of perspective.
One of them is the
disruptive thinking,
is actually believing that as a
startup you can build something
totally new that's going
to change everything
that we know so far and going
to teach people or users
and get them to do stuff that
they haven't done before.
So I think that disruptive
thinking is something
that for sure you can see
here in Silicon Valley
but you can also see in Israel.
Which is very interesting.
Not only mainstream startups
building on other ecosystems
building on other
platforms being
an add on or some cool addition
to it, but just thinking I
can build a new ecosystem, I
can build a new monster company
that's going to
change the world.
So that's one thing that I
think is a great differentiator
especially when
you look at Europe.
A second differentiator is
the hunger, the basic hunger.
You talked about being
scrappy, as we are in Israel,
but the hunger to do things,
the hunger to create,
the hunger to
achieve, the hunger
to step out of your
comfort zone and go and do
crazy stuff although you're
not going to make money
for a lot of time,
maybe not at all,
is another differentiator
that I think
is a very basic, very
primitive, but a very important
element of building a
successful startup industry.
So these are, I think, the
main two differentiators
that I notice.
AARON HARRIS: I don't
think I have much
to add to what you guys said.
It's pretty exhaustive.
AMIR SHEVAT: Oh, yeah.
Of Course.
FADI BISHARA: Yeah.
Just want to add one more thing.
I just agree with Roy.
I think there's some
psychological difference
with the founders that I see.
In Silicon Valley
there is definitely
that belief that you could
go and change the world,
do something.
Outside of here, very difficult
for entrepreneurs to really
have that big thinking mentality
that-- to go for something big.
It's just a self permission
that-- it takes exposure to
and seeing an
example of to adopt.
So I think that's--
you mentioned in Israel
as an ecosystem, but I think
Israel has done a phenomenal
job with building the
entrepreneur ecosystem.
That a lot of the stuff
that is existing in here
is quickly adopted over there.
AMIR SHEVAT: OK.
So I'm going to start with
a question to you, Aaron.
And feel free to fill in.
Do you think that--
how many of you
who are here outside of the US?
OK.
So do you think these
guys should come here
to do their startup?
Does it make sense to come,
if you have a startup,
and at which stage?
If you think that's
wise, at which stage
should they come here?
AARON HARRIS: Yes.
So in our last batch
at YC-- I don't
know what the count is
for this current batch
that we just started.
We had founders
from 23 countries.
And we tell people
and what I tell
anyone I meet who's
from another country
and is thinking about YC
is that it's a great idea
to come here and do YC and
spend the three months here.
Right?
Companies are in
slightly different stages
for doing that, but I
think it's particularly
helpful at the very early
stage for the company
and for the founders,
especially if they've never
seen how things work here.
There's a palpable energy in
Silicon Valley around startups
that is different than
anywhere else in the world.
And it's actually-- it's not
so much the fear of failure
that doesn't exist
here, it's the fact
that it's normal to go
and do this incredibly
crazy and potentially
stupid thing.
And so you have this support
network built in and like all
these you talk to-- I
remember when I left finance
to start my company, everyone
I talked to-- this is in 2010
in New York-- people
were like, eeeeh, really?
Oooh, do you need a job?
I'm like, no, no, I
want to start a company.
And here it's the
exact opposite.
I mean it's changed a little
bit in other parts of the world.
So coming here and then getting
infused with that energy
and with that philosophy
I think is critical.
But then go back to
wherever you came from.
Right?
If you want.
Stay here if you
think that's best,
but if it's best
for your company
to go back to Israel or England
or China or wherever it is,
do that and bring the
philosophy and the energy
that you found here back to
the community that-- from which
you're from.
EDEN SOCHAT: I'd be
concerned about that,
just looking at this.
I think that Silicon Valley
does a lot of times act
as an echo chamber
and you see people
working on similar problems and
not necessarily the problems
that they are the best
equipped at solving.
So we talked about this over
lunch, a company in Israel
called Windward that do--
they pretty much track
every ship in the world in order
to understand where commodities
are flowing around.
What's the oil supply
in Japan in six days?
And you rarely see
these kind of companies
in the Silicon Valley.
There are other problems
that outside-- that as ideas.
So that's one thing that I'm
not sure being situated here
will serve them as well.
And the second point
is talent wise,
hiring here is unbelievably
hard while other countries
have talent pools that
can be tapped easier.
AARON HARRIS: Yeah.
And I think the diversity
of ideas that occurs in--
occurs all over the world.
I don't think that's so
much a function of being
in Silicon Valley
versus not, it's
a question of who
the founding team is
and where they come from.
And so when you have a largely
homogeneous pool of people,
they're going to come
with similar ideas, sure.
That's kind of why I think
that having people come
to YC after they have their
idea, they have an idea,
they have their founding team.
So they come with crazy
ideas from all over the place
and then get the-- like,
the, just the culture of YC
and bring that back.
And as for hiring, yeah,
that's a problem everywhere.
I mean, I guess it's a little
easier in some other countries.
It's harder here but there's
also a larger talent pool here.
But again, go back if you want
to go back to somewhere else
and hire there using the
credentials that you have
of being a YC company
and that helps a lot.
ROY GLASBERG: It's a
difficult question.
You see a lot of startups,
a lot of Israeli startups,
asking, when is the right
time to go to Silicon Valley,
should they go to
Silicon Valley?
I usually try to avoid this
one size fit all answers.
I think it's a very
different from startup
to startup, from technology
to technology, especially
from where eventually the
users are going to be.
But, as a general
rule, or as some--
I think the most startups,
at least that I work
with in Israel, are looking
for the American market,
are looking for American users.
And that's why I think
it's crucial for them
to be here, spend some time,
interact with the people who
are eventually going
to be using the apps
or using their solutions.
Yes, this is a global
world, everybody's
using mostly the same
stuff, but still, it's
very different in mentality.
Another important thing that I
take for the Israeli startups
is working with
VCs, learning how
to present your solution,
how to do the pitch,
how to communicate with
investors, with people that
are from a different mentality.
There's a huge mentality gap
form Israelis to Americans.
So spending time
here is important.
I totally agree that we have a
lot of success stories coming
from Israel where development
remain in Israel, where
the talent stayed there,
and here was more of the,
I would say, the market
touch people that came
or smaller groups came here.
But eventually I
think it's inevitable
that a startup that
wants to work globally,
that wants to work
in the United States,
needs to know the
channeling options here
in the United States.
They want to raise money.
And again, money is a
crucial aspect of this.
If you stay in one ecosystem
and you try and raise money
and you don't
experiment or you don't
go see other options
and other areas
where you can
raise money, you're
pretty limited in Israel.
Money wise we're very limited
on what funds can provide.
Also, there's a
different mentality
and the level of risks the
funds are willing to take.
So going through an area where
they're a little bit more
open to risk-- and
Eden will correct me
on this in two seconds--
I think is, again, it's
like going to one
bank to get an offer
rather than doing
a bank shopping
and see where you can
get the best offer.
FADI BISHARA: So
should you move to--
should you build
your company here
or should you build your
company in the home country.
I answer-- you should build your
But you should also
come here, learn
from here, partner with
here, get the best practices.
And there is a hack
right now, literally,
to building startups.
With being a global
market, definitely the US
is the largest market right
now for technology and changes
and innovation.
But what we could
do in here is we
have the expertise and
experience in Silicon Valley
building startups that we
could loan this experience
and help companies from outside
of Silicon Valley leverage--
turn the liability
into an asset.
The fact that you're
not here-- here
it's very expensive
to hire people,
it's very expensive to-- you're
competing with some of the best
people also for funding
and everything else.
But you can have
access to people
that you went to college
with, people that you've
known from your network.
The talent pool that you may
have in your local community
may be better or richer and
more affordable than accessing
on building your talent here.
So the answer is,
you need to do both.
You need to build a company
with a global perspective.
The hack that I'm
referring to is,
what we're trying
to do at Black Box,
is exactly doing what the
Israeli companies have done.
Set up the company
as a US entity
and operate as a US
company, come here as a CEO,
as a founder doing your
corporate development,
your business development,
your fundraising,
build the relationships.
Silicon Valley is all
based on relationships.
All distribution partners,
all the investors,
they invest in you
as a person and they
want to know you and build
a relationship with you.
So if your team in Pakistan or
in Rome and Berlin, that's fine
as long as you're building
a relationship and you're
showing that you're
moving the needles,
you're doing things
in the right direction
and you're building the
product the right way.
And you could access the
resources of Silicon Valley
by being also in both places.
AMIR SHEVAT: I
just want-- I just
want to follow up on
the relationship thing.
This is very important.
I've seen a lot of
startups do this mistake.
They come for
three days and they
think that they're
going to raise funds.
Please don't do that.
It's like going to a
bar, talking to a person,
and saying, would you like
to get married with me?
OK?
You don't do that, right?
You need to build relationships.
So when you come here, if you're
coming, come for a duration,
come between a few
weeks to a few months.
Two days, you
won't get anything.
You'll get a lot of nice
calls and people here
are very friendly.
They'll say, yes, it's an
interesting idea, thank you,
this is great, you would
like to have some coffee.
But if you want to build
a stronger relationship,
stay here for a
meaningful duration.
EDEN SOCHAT: But really,
really important.
The best way I've found to
date to kill your company
is to have multi-site
before product market fit.
It's a wonderful way to kill it.
It's almost as good as replacing
with a professional CEO, which
is also a great way
to kill the company.
But don't do multi-site
before product market fit.
Meaning don't have split your
company to two locations.
That's my--
AMIR SHEVAT: OK.
So if we're on giving on
tips section, how many of you
have a great idea or a product?
OK.
How many of you have
millions of users right now?
A little bit less?
OK.
So what would be our
tip for distribution?
What is the best way, from
your experience, if you
have a company that you see
and they have a great product,
how can they get
the million users?
How can they become
a big company?
Aaron, do you want
to start with that?
AARON HARRIS: Sure.
There's no one
prescriptive thing
that you can do that will
get you to a million users.
There's all these
really, I think,
funny posts online about here
is the way to growth hack
or, like, here's the way
to grow your company.
And the truth is, depending
on what your company is
and depending on
who your users are,
every company's going to grow
a little bit differently.
And the thing that worked
for the guy last week
is not going to work for you.
So the only exception
to that rule
is basically making something
that people want and like
enough that they're willing
to tell their friends about
and tell other
similar people about.
That's the only thing that
consistently time and again
actually grows your company.
Especially as a startup.
Look, when you are
Gillette and you
have billions of
dollars to spend
on marketing over the
course of the years, fine.
That stuff can work.
But you're not.
And as a startup,
really it's just
making your product so good
that it solves a problem
so well that everyone
wants it and wants
to tell their friends about it.
FADI BISHARA: Yeah.
So I've never build
any product that
had a million users or anything.
But I've seen-- I've worked
with terrific founders locally
and internationally that they've
gotten that kind of traction.
And I think the key to
getting this kind of users
is getting to what
Aaron is saying
is building something
people want.
But getting to that point
is, how do you get there?
How do you build this thing?
Is by understanding, really,
who's your user base?
So if you're building
something for the US market
where there are millions
of people going to be here
for the largest market for
you to put the product out,
you really need to
understand the problem
that you're solving from
this context in here.
And you need to spend enough
time here understanding and do,
whatever it's called-- customer
development-- do it five times
over.
And keep learning and keep
learning, keep learning,
keep understanding.
And validate and understand what
problem are you going to solve
and how are you going
to go about solving it.
So being in a
large enough market
to get that kind of traction is
understanding a market yourself
as a founder to start with.
EDEN SOCHAT: Have
you seen the hack
that was going on recently--
who installed Yo here?
Who installed Yo?
So who is that
terrible-- anyways,
so they hacked
the system, right?
How did they hack the system?
They said, OK, well, what do
bloggers want to write about?
Bloggers want to
write about how stupid
is the ecosystem for
funding something
so stupid with a
million dollars.
So it was brilliant.
Right?
So they actually are the
million users, to your question,
for an absolute bullshit app
because they hacked the system
in order to do that.
So they'll not go
anywhere-- no, no, I'm
not saying-- I'm saying
that more of a antithesis,
I'm not saying you
should do that.
But it's incredible to see
someone playing with the system
because he basically provided
a story for the bloggers
about how stupid he is, and
that turned into number one app
in the US market.
They are still one of
the top five in social.
And it's embarrassing
as everyone in the room
here, to think that this
dynamic actually happened.
So in the 30,000 feet
thing-- and that's something
that recently you saw-- even
just choose your name right.
Which is funny.
It's not the distribution,
it's not nothing about that.
But think of
GetTaxi versus Uber.
GetTaxi is a fairly
successful Israeli company.
That-- what does it do?
Get you a taxi.
So they're not
replacing the taxi,
they're just helping
out the taxi business.
And so they're capped.
So size of company-- forget
the first million users--
but what they're doing, if
you look at San Francisco,
the taxi market is $150 million.
Uber in San Francisco
is doing $400 million.
So obviously they're not
part of the taxi market.
They are not a GetTaxi.
And the Israeli actually
chose the wrong name.
They kind of improved
on the ecosystem
instead of trying to build
or rebuild the ecosystem.
So sometimes, just even the
name is extremely powerful.
It won't get you the first
million, but it will--
it might determine
whether you're
a billion dollar company
or a $10 billion.
ROY GLASBERG: I think there
are two aspects that I
can add because all of the
things that were said here
are brilliant.
But it's consistency, and on
the other hand, flexibility.
A lot of success
stories that you
here, one of them
the uncertainty
or the risk factor
or the patience
of watching it go
through, watching
your ecosystem and
your user base grow.
I mean, if somebody
would have thought
of an app that can predict
in advance the adoption
rate of a service, that would
have an excellent startup
but I don't think
anybody can do it.
So what's left for
entrepreneurs is actually build
that relationship with your
users, get the feedback,
be open to change,
be open to adapt.
I think that
Feature list, as you
can see with all startups
with these road maps,
they're really nice
but they will always
remain kind of
this road map that
probably won't be exercised.
I think that the learning starts
once you have your first user,
you first 100 users,
your first 2,000 users.
If you work good we these
guys, if you listen to them,
if you learn from them
you can continue growing
and continue proceeding
in the right direction.
If you're too stuck
on what you thought
in the beginning
and the feature set
that you thought in
the beginning is what's
going to work, you're
probably not going
to get too far ahead unless you
are this genius who predicted
exactly what's going to happen.
AMIR SHEVAT: The Yo app.
If you predicted the Yo
trends, then you're probably--
ROY GLASBERG: Yo, Yo.
AMIR SHEVAT: Yo.
So I'm now opening the
stage for questions.
So if you have any questions--
I have more, but yep.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I need stages.
Sorry.
You talked about
going into the biggest
market as something of an asset.
What is there to be said
about finding smaller markets
and starring in them?
Let's say you take
the idea of Skype
and have it use a prepaid
in Africa or Eastern Europe
and be a star there in a
much smaller market instead
of fighting with all the
competitors in the US or west
Europe?
AARON HARRIS: So one
thing I would say,
I don't think the
point Eden was making
was that you have to
go into a giant market.
I think what he was saying
is that you don't want
to limit the market that
you're attacking initially.
In fact, what you actually
want to do a lot of the time
is go after market that
other people might not think
is so big.
So if we go back to the
Uber example specifically,
their initial thing
was black cars.
Right?
Which is-- that's the market.
I mean, it's big,
sure, but it's a market
that they could
create dominance in
and then they could
move from there.
So I think that's how
to think about it.
EDEN SOCHAT: And about using
a small market as an example.
Just be cautious that
customer development doesn't
build the product that is
not suitable for the rest
of the world just because you
attack that small segment.
Otherwise, yep, a niche
is a good starting point.
AUDIENCE: So what do you do
when you have a company that
has millions of users, has
revenues, has not been invested
in, and is basically--
at what point
would you actually
talk to Silicon Valley?
And what approach would
you use to do that to grow?
FADI BISHARA: So it
depends on your needs.
So you're growing but you're
not growing as fast as you'd
like to grow, and
what is the limit.
Is it if you have more
revenues, if you have more money
to invest, you grow faster?
AUDIENCE: Yes. [INAUDIBLE].
FADI BISHARA: OK.
So that's the point to talk.
If you have a proven
business that's
got a good traction,
good numbers.
This is a good point to
talk to Silicon Valley.
And the way you do it, you
don't come for three days
like Amir said no matter
how good your Excel
sheet and your hockey
stick looks like.
You need to come here
and build relationships,
find the right kind of investors
that they would invest in you
and give you the kind of
guidance where you could think
your company from a $10
million revenue to $100
million revenues with the
right amount of investments.
So you come to Silicon Valley
with that kind of open mind,
understanding that you
don't necessarily may
have all the answers but you
have already proven something
that is working, especially
if it's working in the US.
It's a good time to
come to Silicon Valley.
EDEN SOCHAT: Where are you from?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMIR SHEVAT: So there was
a hidden question there
which is, why do
you need the money?
Another mistake I see
startups do a lot is
try to get money
without knowing what
they'll do with that money.
And no, getting money
is a full time job.
I've been talking to
entrepreneurs who have not
been doing features, who
have not been doing customer
research because they're
focused on creating better
presentations for VCs.
OK?
That's not your role
as an entrepreneur.
If you want you
can open an agency
that creates
presentations for VC.
It might be a good business
but as entrepreneur
you need to create
good businesses.
Right?
So know the time that
you need the money, know
why you need the
money, and that's it.
FADI BISHARA: Yeah.
I mean an example
is [INAUDIBLE].
Their first run was $60 million.
I mean, you could
just grow as fast
as you can and on your own.
You may connect with special
expert advisers and mentors
and grow your board
of directors or board
of advisers with
experienced people
in this domain who built similar
business to multiple larger
sites.
AMIR SHEVAT: We'll
take one more question.
Two more questions, I
guess, if they're quick.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I have a question.
Is there any program where
you can helping entrepreneurs
in Latin America?
Are you working every-- do
you guys in your organization?
FADI BISHARA: Are you asking
if we help entrepreneurs
from South America?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMIR SHEVAT: Black
Box for the LatAm.
FADI BISHARA: No, no.
We have a Black Box for
international entrepreneur.
One of the highest value
that we've discovered
is the diversity
of entrepreneurs
coming from different countries
versus bringing entrepreneurs
only from Latin America or only
from Israel only from Sweden.
So it's-- you participate.
This is a global game.
EDEN SOCHAT: Are you familiar
with Wayra Telefonica?
They actually have a lot of
programs in South America
so you should-- if you don't
know them, check them out.
They're actually fairly active.
AUDIENCE: My question
is, why is it,
whether it's in Silicon Valley
or elsewhere, the focus is
only on consumer facing--
consumer products?
And on that, can
we have a couple
of tips for entrepreneurs who
are starting B2B businesses.
EDEN SOCHAT: If
anything, by the way,
if look at the ecosystem right
now in the Silicon Valley,
Andreessen said we're not
doing any investing in consumer
until it's B round.
It's a sentiment and
it's a sinus wave
and every sometime
something else
is more cool than
the other things.
But today, actually
you should be
in a better shape raising
B2B money in Silicon Valley.
Israel is a bit at a shift.
So there's still consumers
still available capital for it.
But you should actually
be in a better shape.
And B2B, in general, it's
not consumer traction but as
much as actual
design partnerships
that you work with customers
that say, I love this.
Sometimes you actually
still do manual work
so it's not fully
automated, but they
love the value proposition.
That's the most,
at least for me,
seeing that customers
actually want
what you have is the
number one thing.
FADI BISHARA: I kind of--
it's kind of interesting
when you presume that
most startups always
start with this kind
of consumer product,
especially first time
entrepreneurs, especially
entrepreneurs who are
just out of college.
That's probably
what's given this.
The one tip that
I would give you
if you're starting
a B2B company is
to have worked at a
big company before.
And many, many
entrepreneurs right now
they're just coming
out of college,
they haven't had jobs
at big corporations.
To understand the real pain
or how this big elephant,
big giant corporations operate.
And so they avoid it
and they go to a Yo.
And that's-- that's where-- I
think the opportunity is if you
want to do B2B is
tremendous right now.
We, in our program, we accept
15 companies in a quarter.
And this run we have
10 companies that
[? do ?] and they're
all B2B technologies.
AMIR SHEVAT: So we're
running out of time.
I have just one more
comment about B2B.
Think about sales cycles.
So sales cycles and B2B are
very different than sales cycles
in B2C.
So think about how you
structure a company in the way
that you can work with
that sales cycles.
So I'm sorry, we're
running out of time.
But these guys are
going to stay here
and we're going to--
we'll be happy to take
off-line questions.
Thank you very much.